(electronic tones)
- Dr. Mendoza is going to speak more,
as Dr. Weiss commented, on
the impact of Immigration,
Trauma and Children and
Youth with Disabilities,
Fernando, welcome.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
Lucy, thank you very much.
So I'm talking about immigration.
I have no disclosures except one.
I'm a child of an immigrant.
How many of you have parents
that were not born in this country?
So as Paul talked about violence,
violence has been around a long time.
My grandfather fought in
the Mexican Revolution
with Poncho Villa, got shot four times,
by our family history.
He decided that was not
a safe place to live,
so he came with his family,
worked on the railroads
and then in the, as a farm worker
and brought his family to California.
That's my dad.
My parents raised me.
You know that's me, child
has a very big head.
(audience laughs)
But I think that's the
history that we have.
But the history that I grew up with
was immigrants are
welcome, there's hope here.
But as one gets older and
looks at the real history,
you see things like the reality
that they're not always welcome.
And indeed if we look at our history,
and this is something that
actually I didn't know much about
until recently, but in the 1930s,
U.S. citizens who were Mexican,
by the government were
deported back to Mexico.
Among that group was my mother.
And at 91, she felt that that was the most
traumatic experience in her whole life.
So I think that immigration
and the kinds of things
that happen are really powerful.
So what I'd like to do is
sort of cover these areas.
It's gonna be sort of a fast oversight,
demographic, social
determinants, health status,
utilization, policies, and then
what I think we need to do.
And these are the learning goals.
I think that, at the end of the day,
those of us in health professions
need to understand something
about immigrant kids,
the social determinants,
their health status,
how they differ, list some of the factors
of what are the problems in utilization,
understand some of the
policies that we're looking at
in terms of how they apply to this group,
and lastly, and lastly is to talk about
is our system ready to see these kids?
Demographics, I use that picture
'cause that's what we look like.
Last year, 2018, we went through this.
This is the demographics
of the United States.
This is where half, that
50%, half of the population,
the red line is kids.
That line last year crossed at 50%.
That says that half of all the kids
in the United States are minority.
That line here, adults will
cross in the next 20 years,
where half of the population
in the United States will be minority.
This is what the population
of kids looks like,
primarily minority, with
the largest group Latino.
Now how did we get there?
Well actually, if you look at,
and I would encourage you to look
at the history of
immigration, the policies.
Prior to 1965, our country used quotas
to let people immigrate.
And those quotas were basically
from Northern European countries.
In 1965 with Civil Rights,
there was a new immigration law passed,
and that law said we really wanna look
at how to bring families together.
And if you look in 1974,
the immigration to this
country dramatically changed,
as you can see here, much more
for Latin America, Mexico and Asia.
So what that's led to is a dynamic
of change of the demographics.
And this is a map of the
primary groups of immigrants.
So although there are
many different immigrants,
you see that the major
group here is from Mexico.
But then you see other
countries as noted here,
from Africa, from other
parts of the world.
I think that's important to understand,
but the other part of
this, the other reason
the wall will not work to
stop the demographic shift,
is the birth rates of these groups, right?
So 40% of the immigrant
population from Mexico,
they have 32% of the
growth of immigrant kids,
Central America 11%, 17% of the growth.
But look at Asia, 9%
but 23% of the growth.
In the last several decades,
75% of the increased growth in children
has been from Latinos and Asian Americans.
Without that, we would
have a negative population
among kids, which would not be
good for those of us over 65.
(audience laughs)
That has brought, that
diversity has brought languages.
There are 350 languages
spoken in the United States.
If you look at this, this is
the number of languages here.
This is the number of people.
But I want you to look at this,
if you can't see it,
major metropolitan areas.
This is San Francisco area.
There's more than 150 languages
spoken, 150 languages.
Each of those languages,
different culture,
different way of thinking, right?
If we look over here, we see
that the totality of those
that do not speak English
at home in the United States
is like 21%, 8% more or less
that are not fluent in English.
But look at California.
We're looking at 44% that do
not speak English at home, 44%,
and almost 20% that are
limited English-proficient.
Silicon Valley, 66% of the households
do not speak English in the house, right?
That's America, that's new America.
So when we look at the United States
and I show you that demographic,
California is 20 years ahead
of the rest of the nation.
So we are living in the future
for the rest of the
nation demographically.
Silicon Valley is even in front of that.
And to understand that as
health professions is key
because this is not gonna go back.
We have to anticipate what that means
and how we practice and
what, how we see kids.
So what is the social determinants?
What are these groups like, right,
because indeed we need to
think, not only about diversity,
but something about what
exactly is going on with them.
This is the sort of model
that the World Health
and CDC use to think
about population health.
Now I want you to use this
to think about immigrant populations.
And we see that the totality of the circle
is the population health.
This little part up here is genetics.
Our institution spent a
lot of time on genetics,
but it's only that little part.
And yet when we look at the other parts
of health care access, health
behaviors, as important,
but we think about what
are health behaviors?
Health behaviors comes out
of how people are raised,
how people live, right?
And that plays into the
rest of the ecology.
How, what's the environment they lived in?
Paul just talked about environments
that are really traumatic.
Well, you know, we have to
think about what trauma is
and relative to how people live.
These are the things that we
usually think about, right,
poverty, low education, racism,
cultural differences, languages, isms.
I think we also should think
about how disenfranchised
people are from institutions.
But now we're thinking about
the issue of immigration
because among those social determinants,
somebody signing a bill
can change them, right?
We can't change poverty
really by just signing a bill,
but we can change immigration
by somebody signing a bill.
And that's really important.
Let me just start off
with what's the difference
between a refugee and an immigrant?
So UN High Commission,
these are the definitions.
People that migrate and
immigrate for economic reasons
is different than a refugee.
A refugee has to leave the country
because they're in danger in
their life or in their freedom.
And we have honored that for generations.
We have been that place that
allows refugees to come in.
We've been that place
that have allowed immigrants to come in.
The question is are we still that place?
For immigrant kids, or
children in immigrant families,
which we define as one
parent not born in the U.S.,
this is what they looked at.
And this is in 2009,
but basically the same.
So this group is U.S. kids,
that is a U.S. citizen kid
with parents that are documented.
This is U.S. citizen kids.
This is kids with documentation.
And only this little sliver
here, which about 6% in 2009,
it's down to about 4% now,
are children that are undocumented.
So in essence when we talk about children
in immigrant families, we're talking
about either U.S. citizens,
which now is about 90%,
or kids that have been documented.
Here is the problem.
This section here are kids
that are U.S. citizens
or documented but have
undocumented parents.
What that means to us is the following.
This is the U.S.
We see that among the
immigrants in the U.S.,
about 30% or so have
an undocumented parent.
But look at California.
One third of all the kids in California
that are living in immigrant families
of an undocumented parent, 17%.
What is 17%?
One out of every six kid
that you see has an undocumented parent.
What does that mean?
If we look at television,
we know what it means.
It means that kids go to school worried
about when they come home,
whether their parent will be there.
Dad goes to work, they're worried
about am I gonna see
my father this evening?
Now think about the
times in your own lives
when you've had, even when you were small,
the possibility that you
weren't gonna see your parent?
What trauma, even for
the instant, that caused.
Think about it, living
that type of environment
for a long period of
time, what does that mean?
So I think that one of the things
that we're concerned about
here is that demographic,
the way we look at social determinants
and whether you're legal
as a child is one thing,
but more importantly whether
your parent is legal or not,
and what is their status?
And even if they're legal,
even if they have papers,
is that gonna change by
somebody signing a bill,
by having somebody say well,
you no longer have
permission to stay here.
What are the other things
that we need to understand
about children in immigrant families?
This is something I want
you to kinda think about
because these are not homogeneous groups.
These are very heterogeneous.
And they're heterogeneous
because they're coming
from different countries
with different experiences
and different social classes.
This is one thing that we all look at,
the social structure of the family.
And what we see here is children
with two-parent families,
here are native, here's
the immigrant population,
and you see these are different groups
across the spectrum here
from Mexico, Central America,
Southeast Asia, Asia, European, Africa.
So even by that, you can see well,
most children in immigrant families
on the average live in
two-parent families.
But they also have
differences in education.
This is less than than a
high school, dark purple,
gray high school, college.
And you see that for Mexico,
very few have college.
Most, a number have less
than a high school education,
primarily primary school.
But then we see the spectrum here,
and some of these groups have
70% that are college educated.
Could look at Silicon
Valley, the engineers
that come from all over the world,
that's part of the
immigrant population, right?
So that sets up a different dynamic
when we think about this,
and yet they still have
that cultural issue,
which is language at home.
You see, almost all of
them have a predominance
of speaking other than English at home.
What education does,
and is really set you up
for whether you're gonna
live in poverty or not.
And as we see in educational framework,
the Mexican-American population here,
which is the largest immigrant population,
has the highest level of
both below poverty line
and 100%, or up to 200% poverty
line, almost two thirds.
So for some groups, this
is really significant,
that they live in poverty.
Here's the average for natives.
And in other groups they're lower.
So as we think about children
in immigrant population,
particularly you in San Francisco,
you're gonna see lots of different groups.
And yet we shouldn't just
look at the social class,
we shouldn't just look
at the immigrant status.
We need to look at the totality
of what the characteristics
of those families are.
What about their health status?
This is a painting from
Carmen Lomas Garza,
who does a lot of things about the culture
of different groups.
I love this because you can see
it's sort of the folk medicine.
And yet it brings up the
issue that a lot of times,
even if you're educated, you
still have a lot of beliefs
that are fundamentally cultural, right?
We all do.
When we look at immigrants and refugees,
we need to distinguish what
exactly has happened to them.
And I see kids in clinic,
and we see them from
all over Latin America.
And one of the things we try to do
is assess what has
happened to them, right?
So although a majority of
the kids that I showed you
from that round circle are U.S. born,
there's a large section that are refugees
or kids that are first-generation,
that is born outside
the U.S. that come here.
These are the things
that we need to decide.
Are they refugees, and I'll show you
why that's so important, but
basically they get services,
or are they immigrants
who may not get services?
What was their social class?
Even from Mexico, I can see families
that were living in Mexico City,
parents are well-to-do, and I see them.
They're different than somebody
that comes from the
(speaks foreign language)
and, you know, a sixth grade education.
So that's the dynamic of
education and social class
that they may have in their country.
Trauma coming to this country,
the trauma, as Paul points out,
is both in the home and at coming here.
I had one father that came
in with two daughters,
fairly well-dressed
and lived in Guatemala,
and I asked him well
what are you doing here?
And I mean they had funds and everything.
He said the gangs told me
unless I gave them my business
they would kill my kids.
So you know Paul points out why
does somebody take the risk?
Well what risk is there if
your kids are gonna get killed
versus coming here and trying
to get through the system?
That's not a hard risk to take, right?
So we do have lots of
families that have a trauma,
not just coming across,
but from their prior
history in their country.
Trauma, clearly you've heard stories,
and those stories are very much true,
that coming across the
border is dangerous.
It physically can be, has
physical abuse, sexual abuse,
and just the psychological trauma
of coming through the process
of getting to the United States
and getting through the
border patrol and all that,
that is traumatic, and Paul
showed some of the things
that are going on.
I'll talk a little bit more about that.
But that's another assessment.
Moreover, what has happened
to the current immigration status?
And lastly, do they have any support here?
Are they here with other family members?
Do they have other things
that will help them support?
When we look at other
factors in terms of health,
we have to think, as Paul points out,
you know, are these kids coming healthy,
or are they have
problems, chronic disease,
malnutrition, infectious disease?
On the average, they tend not
to be physically too unhealthy,
but I think the psychological
stress is really quite high.
And lastly when we think about health,
the two things that I think
have been quite remarkable,
one is that the expectation,
particularly those first-generation kids
that are coming seem to
be over several decades
not as bad as we thought
they would once they're here,
that is even though parents have poverty,
they don't have very high education,
their kids' health status
seems to be relatively okay.
And that turns out to be
what people have called
the immigrant paradox,
the paradox that in this country
usually if you have
poverty, low education,
low social class, your health is poor.
This group tends to at least seemed,
at least in surveys, seems to indicate
that they're not as
poor as we would expect.
That's the paradox.
Here's the problem, though.
The longer they stay in this country,
the worse their health gets.
I was on the Institute
of Medicine's committee
for immigrant kids in the late 1990s.
That was astonishing, 'cause
everything we looked at,
health, mental health,
education got worse.
So we ended up by saying
America may be toxic.
And yet that's important
to understand why.
Why do people change?
What things should we not
change and keep them healthy?
That's something we don't know.
Let me show you a little
bit of those things.
Here's birth weight, right,
birth weight's really important.
This is something from the 1990s.
We did a study in the '80s,
the studies that are done now,
those red bars are all
women that are immigrants.
And their proportion of low birth weight
is always lower than native-born.
I want to point out one
particular one from Africa.
Look at the difference
between African-Americans
born in this country
and African-Americans,
or Africans born in other countries.
There's no program
that decreases low birth weight that much.
That is true for all across.
We look at infant
mortality, all those things,
it's the same picture.
Using the National Survey
of Children's Health,
these are the odds ratios
of comparing immigrants here
to third generations.
And what we see here,
the reds are significant
that many of these things
that we think about
as developmental issues
are, for the most part,
lower in children in immigrant families.
Now remember, these are a small proportion
of first-generation,
the majority is second-generation, okay?
Now the question will be
is that because they just don't know?
Hard to say, 'cause
first-generation would get access
to health care, right,
or second-generation.
So what we see here is, for example
behavioral problems less, depression less,
a little bit hard for me to see there,
depression, autistic
disorders same, interesting,
and all the rest are lower.
But even with just
looking at insured kids,
so everybody has access,
they're still lower.
So the question to us as
investigators in pediatrics,
what is that?
What factor can we find that
could be very useful to us
to understand that this helps families?
Is it the culture?
Is it social connectedness?
Is it how people rear their kids?
We don't know, but it is
important to investigate.
But here's the other problem.
The longer they stay in this
country, the worse it gets.
This is U.S. born, and these
are then by the time state,
or living in the United
States things get worse.
And whether that's asthma
or chronic disease,
they all get worse.
Now some of that is behaviors.
While new immigrants don't smoke as much,
as they stay here they smoke more,
they drink more, et cetera, right?
So this is something that
as we look at prevention,
we need to think about
what are those things
that immigrant families
do that we wanna support
and not change?
Allow them not to be Americanized,
but allow them to keep their culture.
What about health care utilization?
Well, I use these two,
again photo from a painting
from Carmen Lomas Garza.
Families may be using both.
They may use folk medicine
at home, don't tell you,
and then they may come to you
to get health care, right?
So that's something that I think we
as health practitioners need
to think about and work with.
The issue of looking at this
as you know primarily health
insurance is important,
because indeed one of
the things that we have
in this country is if you
don't get health insurance,
then you're probably not gonna
get access to care, right?
Now what's interesting about immigrants
and different groups of immigrants
is almost all immigrants work.
And you see that sort of black green bar
is the proportion that work.
But the immigrants that work with jobs
that get health insurance,
like this group here
which are non, basically immigrants
from non-Latin American countries,
it's much larger than
immigrants from Mexico that work
but rarely get health insurance.
And that is because at the end of the day,
they're working in jobs that
don't provide health insurance
or work part-time jobs, right?
And therefore they tend to have
the largest uninsured group.
And among Latinos in general,
those that are first-generation,
clearly undocumented are ones
that are gonna have less health insurance.
So you know, as we look forward,
this is the group that's most at-risk,
the group that's
first-generation, undocumented,
and even though they're working
sometimes two or three jobs,
they still don't get health care.
And this demonstrates that issue more so
in the sense that when we
look at no health insurance,
Hispanic children in immigrant families,
one in four does not
have health insurance,
no preventative care, 16%,
and did not receive mental health.
While that's common among all these
among the largest immigrant group,
they rarely get mental health.
And yet if you think about
who needs it the most,
it's those groups that have
tried to come across the border
that have had trauma and are dealing
with post traumatic stress,
dealing with depression, anxiety.
And where they show up
sometimes in our clinic,
but you know one of the problems
that we all have, as you know,
is where do we get those
kinds of services long-term?
Do we go to schools?
And, you know, do you send
them to psychiatrists?
How many psychiatrists
are there for children?
Do you send them for
mental health therapists?
How many mental health
therapists speak Spanish
or other languages?
Hard to do mental health
if you can't speak to them.
So that is a real challenge for us,
and I think in utilization
although we can get them
through the part of insurance,
access to care is gonna be important.
Now what I said previously is
that we have here a situation
where if you're a refugee
or you're U.S. born,
then you get health care.
And this table here shows that,
that if you're a U.S. citizen child
with undocumented parents, this one here,
you see that you're eligible
because you're a U.S. citizen, right?
But if you're pregnant and
if you're not undocumented,
it's unclear whether you get,
if you are undocumented, rather,
it's unclear whether
you get access to care.
Even if you have lawful
documentation to be in this country,
in some states they will
not give you any services
for five years.
They want you to be a
good person for five years
before they give you anything.
Luckily in our state that's
not happened and others.
Whether, also whether
you're under 18, over 18,
that's a situation.
But if you're a refugee, again
this is why it's so important
to determine whether you're a refugee,
you get services across the board.
So the people that are
coming up to the border,
they wanna be let in because of the trauma
and the things that Paul talked about,
but you know, we all see
in the news everyday.
And the way that they
can get in is being asked
that they're in threat for
their life, which they are.
And if they become refugees,
have refugee status,
then they end up getting all the services
that we would want to give them.
This last group, though, is a group
that we're particularly interested in,
is undocumented parents,
women that deliver.
And I'll show you in a minute a study
that we've done with this group,
but this is a group that's having babies,
and yet they don't have
access to services.
Now think about that
prior infant mortality
and low birth weigh I showed you.
Even without services,
they still do pretty well.
But that doesn't mean
that they don't have health care issues.
And it clearly, that just
puts them more at risk.
So one of the things that needs to be done
is thinking about how we change this
to make sure that everybody gets care.
Unfortunately the dynamics
of our government right now
is in a bit of a turmoil,
and I think one of the things
that we need to think
about is how can we impress
upon our policy leaders about
what this actually means.
What does this mean on the ground level?
What does it mean day to day
for our kids and families?
Now as I said, you know,
this has been something
that sort of disrupted the
politics of this country,
and this picture here, this
figure here shows that.
So undocumented children are not eligible
for any health, federal
health care services,
and even those that are, as I just said,
sometimes it takes five years
for them to get anything.
The green states, California
being one of the early ones,
Santa Clara County being
one of the early ones,
said kids are important,
they oughta get health care.
And they gave health care to all kids
independent of whether
they were documented
or not documented U.S. citizens or not.
That was the right thing to do.
That was the humane thing to do.
And if you see here, that that has spread
throughout California and
through the green states.
The blue states give access
to use Medicaid dollars
to help those documented
immigrants to get care.
And the gray states just
think those kids don't exist.
So that's the status of
our country right now.
It's fractured.
It's different people
valuing different things.
Now I'd like to think
that it's really not
valuing different things,
but not having the
knowledge or perspective
of what it means, right?
And I think giving the
knowledge and perspective
of what this means is really important
because the folks that we're
talking about can't speak up.
They don't have a voice.
We're the ones that have a voice,
and we're the ones that
kind of need to do this
and bring this to the forefront.
So let's talk about barriers in,
having to do with disabilities.
What are those, well, I
think you can think about it
just from what I've discussed, right?
Health insurance, if you
don't have health insurance
it's hard to get to
someplace and get care.
The immigration issues, the fear of that,
and yet you know, we're here to serve.
We're here to provide those services.
There was a study by Lin in pediatrics
that looked at autistic
spectrum disorders,
developmental delay, looking at immigrant,
children in immigrant families,
and they were twice as likely
to lack a usual source of care
and have poor communication.
So this is across the country,
that even though they have
access, for U.S. kids,
remember most of these kids are U.S. born.
They still have that problem
of getting through the system.
As I looked at this, it would
remind me of the IOM studies
that have been out in terms
of what are the problems
of getting care to kids,
and it talks about access,
it talks about bias of physicians,
problems in our system.
There's a study in Canada
that you're seeing here
that comes up with the same things,
basically identifying challenges
where the lack of cultural
competency among the providers,
communication issues,
can't talk to the family
'cause we don't speak the same language,
health beliefs, they
believe something different
than what we do, lack of rapport,
it's hard to relate to somebody
if you can't talk to them,
and developing patient-centered
and self-advocacy.
So as you know, it's really important
for kids or any family
that has a chronic disease
to be able to advocate for themselves.
How do we end up doing that with families
that have different
culture, different language,
different kinds of backgrounds, right?
That is a challenge.
We have, we're in the
process of just completing
and submitting a paper where we looked
at the California Health Interview Survey
of all of California, and
looked at the families
that were limited English
proficient, which is a pretty,
it's about a third of all
the kids in California.
Those families reported a lower rate
of communication with their physicians.
And the calculation here showed
that they had a 60% less likelihood
of having effective communications.
So think about all those
things I've talked about
in the risk factors,
particularly the environment
and the prevention and
the social determinants.
How do we get to that if
we can't talk to them,
if we can't communicate with them, right?
That's a challenge.
And we have to really
be very introspective
to ask that question of ourselves.
How effective are we as
communicators with these families
because we know if we're not effective,
our treatments are gonna not
be very effective, either.
This was an interesting study
because it brought to light
that this issue is not just an
issue for us in this country.
It's an issue for around the world,
and Paul spoke about this.
This is a paper out of Chile
where they did a literature
review for the last decade,
2006 to 16, 107 articles,
about half from Europe,
a third from this country.
What they found was something
that you look at these things,
you say yeah, of course, it happens here,
higher use of hospitals and ERs
by this population, all right.
Seeking care was affected
by the cultural norms,
models of disease, lack
of safety networks,
language barriers, economic
and social adversity.
So these were things that
we look around the world,
they're consistent.
And you would say of
course they're consistent
'cause they're all going
through the basic same thing.
They're coming to a country
that is not like them,
may not welcome them, and
is not set up to treat them.
So why would we be expecting
anything different?
They also access factors,
family related difficulties,
navigating systems, underline that one,
and the lack of basic rights,
that not understanding
what rights do they have.
But this last one I
think is also important.
It's something that the
Institute of Medicine
has brought up a lot of times,
which is the health professions barriers,
our biases, our
stereotypes, our prejudices,
language and communication barriers.
At Stanford we've been
looking at unconscious bias,
and I reviewed the literature
for the last 10 years.
And what's kinda sad is
that the IOM came out
in 2002 or so, said we need to think
about how we deal with
our unconscious bias.
And if you look at the
literature for the last 10 years,
that continues to report the idea
that physicians in health professions
have unconscious bias
that impacts health care
in a negative way.
So even though we get a national report,
none of that has changed.
So that's something particularly
for kids most at risk,
the kids that you all see,
that we need to think
about how we change that.
Immigration and social policies,
the wall, Paul's been at Brownsville.
I went there, too.
What's interesting is to see these kids
and to see that they
almost feel safer here.
And in fact they probably are
'cause in their country,
they're getting shot at.
They're getting physically
abused, sexually abused.
The problem is that our refugee policy
tends to change sometimes with a memo
or with somebody signing
something as it has, right?
So we as a country need to think about
what do we want our country to stand for
when we think about refugees?
And that is important.
And that, hopefully our people in Congress
will start kind of being
more adult about this issue.
Parents and children, the fear,
yeah clearly you don't have
to imagine this too much,
but what does it do to somebody
to go through this process?
You're not only living in
terror in your country,
you're coming to this country
and then having to go through all this.
More importantly, even if you get through,
that's not the end.
Even if you get refugee status,
you have to live with all that drama.
And in this country you also
have to live with the fact
that you're an immigrant,
and what that means
and how people, as our president does,
talks about that, right?
I don't know what the long-term effects
of that's gonna be for our kids,
but I'm concerned that that
has significant impact.
It can have significant impact.
Finally, if we think
about immigration policy,
again, encourage you
to look at the history
of immigration in this country.
It has been to really
control what we look like,
how we think.
And I think it's been
mostly looking at adults.
We have never thought about
how those policies affect kids.
And yet we need to think about that
'cause at the end of the
day, what I hope I showed you
is not about the small
percentage, though significant,
of kids that are first-generation.
It's about the larger percentage
that are U.S. citizens
that are gonna be American adults
trying to advance this country forward,
that to live in a situation
where you don't know what's
gonna happen to your parents.
We think about ACEs, one of those things
is really, you know, what
happens to you as a child.
That to me is something
that our legislation
needs to think about, is that families
with undocumented parents
can cause a real stress
in the lives of kids.
Documentation and getting to that process
can be quite traumatic, and particularly
when the lines for that change.
Public charge, recently
the Trump administration
wanted to change public
charge and what it meant.
And it meant that if your
kid got food in school,
that was a public charge.
And I think that those
people that stood up
and said that's not the thing we wanna do
are people that are looking at this
as what we wanna do with
our immigrant population.
DACA, you know these are
kids that were brought here.
They had no say in that process.
And yet we're still battling with DACA.
And we see from reports of that group
that they're successful,
they do all kinds of things.
Several of my students at
Stanford are DACA students.
I'm sure there are DACA students
in all of our medical schools.
Paul brought up, you know, what's happened
for the future of this.
And I think one of the issues
is at the end of the day,
we don't know what happens
to kids that go through war.
We don't know what happens long-term
for kids that come as refugees.
I would say to you I don't
know what's gonna happen
when you have a child
who comes home every day
because the mother's undocumented,
doesn't know whether the
mother's gonna be there.
What is the long-term effects
of that for development,
for depression, for anxiety,
for even just belief what
this country's about, right,
I think those are things that
we need to be concerned about,
and certainly something
that worries me a lot.
Yeah, we can do something.
We did a study, my colleagues
at the Immigration Policy Lab
and I and General Peds.
We looked at DACA from Oregon,
and we were able to identify women
that were eligible for
DACA and had babies.
And those babies could be followed.
And what we found was that
the children of parents
that had DACA eligibility had kids
that had half as much
mental health disorders
as those that did not.
One policy impacting those
kids by decreasing half
of the mental health issues.
So that to me says that one policy
set together by the
President's executive order
rather than Congress, has
major impact on child health.
So I think it just says, you know,
how government can actually be positive.
It doesn't always have to be negative.
So here's what I think has to change.
Immigration policies, I
know we have to have laws,
but we have to have laws that
are supportive of families,
that if we're gonna do whatever processing
we have to with the law,
it has to be sensitive to the family,
and this, I think, particularly
with ICE and refugee processing.
DACA needs to be supported
and finalize the path to citizenship.
I really believe that our
parents who are undocumented,
have U.S. citizens, need
to have that path as well.
We can't have U.S. citizens
lose their parents,
particularly when they're,
you know, six months old,
a year old, five years old.
We have to make sure that public charge
does not take away that threat
of understanding what public charge is
to not take away services to kids,
to not inhibit families from
using services for their kids.
I think that the state
and local governments here
have done a great job.
I've talked about health
insurance for all those kids
that were undocumented.
We led the way.
That spread throughout the nation,
as we can see here with these things.
But lastly I think we need
to have insightful thoughts
about how we practice.
Clearly my deanship has been
in diversifying our workforce.
It needs to continue.
50% of all the kids in
California are Latino,
5% of the pediatricians.
And not that they have to be matched up,
but there's a concern there.
Cultural competency training,
our schools don't do that all that well.
Unconscious bias training, likewise.
These are important things
if we're gonna have a society
that's diverse because there's no way
even for me being Latino to
understand every Latino patient.
And certainly I don't
speak all these languages.
How do you provide a person
like a physician or a health
profession the ability
to function in a very dynamic society
that has all kinds of diversity?
I think interpreters need
to be instituted more,
which has been problematic
a bit because of resources.
But lastly I think in the
realm of health care providers,
we need to partner with communities,
with community workers,
(speaks foreign language)
'cause at the end of the
day what we're looking at
is how not just to treat
people in the office,
but that ecology that I talked about.
We need to think about how we affect that.
Lastly our health care
system needs to change,
and that clearly improving
literacy for our families,
how they access the care, make it easier,
truly make it patient-centered,
and last but not least
make them empowered.
When I was growing up in the '50s,
Norman Rockwell was a person to me
that sort of exemplified
what America was about, right,
he had these classic pictures.
This is one I like because
at the end of the day,
it just said this is a country
that we respect everybody.
We want everybody to be involved
through the Golden Rule.
And I think that sometimes
we need to stand up
for what we believe in,
this country stands for.
And I think this is probably the time,
particularly for our kids
because if we can do that,
we're not just standing up
for the kids and their families.
As I pointed out, we're
standing up for the future.
And that future is gonna
be from these kids, right?
So I wanna thank you for listening,
and we can answer some
questions, thank you.
(audience applauds)